des clients souriant et nombreux à la
pizzeria césar bas et simonetta noni la
terrasse n'a pas désempli dans la soirée
du mercredi 9 juin
cette journée marquait une nouvelle
étape dans le déconfinement il est
désormais possible de manger en
intérieur et surtout le couvre-feu était
repoussé à 23 heures ça changeait tout
parce que c'est pas que ça nous permet
de faire des services et pas l'essentiel
c'est surtout que l'éclair puisse avoir
le temps de manger tranquillement qu'ils
soient pas pressés de partir les gens
qui arrivent avant t on vers dizaine ou
parfois 20h45 pour les aviser écouter
les desserts on voulait mais important
peut pas vous servir
c'était vraiment assez désagréable
c'était un petit au mercer en fait le
restaurant est idéalement situé à
proximité du château de versailles
si les touristes internationaux ne
sommes pas encore revenus les français
de tout l'hexagone se sont bien présents
a décidé d'aller à versailles pour
visiter le château de versailles donc
combat visited main mais on a dit on à
venu un jour auparavant pour profiter de
l'ouverture des restaurants pourront
justement parce que c'est ce qu'on
attend depuis longtemps pour profiter un
peu des terrasses et puis si le temps ne
nous permet alors ça c'est impeccable
parce qu'à strasbourg y pleut
actuellement à donc on a fait le bon
choix je pense et ses clients n'étaient
pas retourner au restaurant depuis des
mois ce couvre-feu à 23h les a motivés
ça l'est déjà au niveau des restaurants
parce qu'on peut mieux choisir les
restaurants les terrasses et puis bon
effectivement d'avoir le temps c'est
quand même très appréciable même si des
clients pouvaient aller en intérieur
peut on fait ce choix en raison du temps
prochaine étape du déconfinement le 30
juin
les restaurants pourront ouvrir à 100%
leur jauge en intérieur et le couvre feu
sera supprimé